the 2010 Broadway revival and that was
where you first played dry and Rose and
Micheal T Williams sin and Stephen
Henderson played their parts in the
revival can you talk a little bit about
how that how that play came about and
and your first experience is getting to
know these characters Scott Rudin called
me in in 2009 and said he has the
screenplay that August wrote and I read
it and I realized I hadn't read the play
and when I read the play it said Troy
Matteson 53 I'm thinking I was too young
to play Troy because I was thinking back
in the 80s when I saw James Earl Jones
and I realized I was gonna be too old if
I didn't hurry up so I called Scott and
I and said I want to do to play and
that's what we did
and so what was your experience first
getting to play this character on stage
I always tease Denzel about this because
when we started rehearsal I was so
nervous because we were following
performances with people absolutely
tattooed their artistry on these roles
but I said okay I have experience I'm
going to rely on my experience and I
remember Denzel at the first rehearsal
said you know I can't forget Mary
Alice's oh my god you know what the
thing about it is you can't miss with
August the words carry you exactly where
you need to go it is a role for Rose I
one of the things I always say she is
absolutely complete her journey is
absolutely complete it is no excess
baggage nothing it's almost like being a
you know I guess you have to be a surfer
but but just riding the wave and then it
takes you where you where you need to go
well Tata August Wilson passed away in
two
thousand five so could you talk a little
bit about what happened what was
happening with the screenplay between
the between his passing the revival and
and the filming in 2000 I understand and
tell me I'm wrong
paramount bought it in the 80s the the
rights to the play and for Eddie Murphy
Eddie Murphy was going to play the son
and as is often the case which a lot of
you know out there development takes a
long time a long time and they developed
it and then other actors came on and
then the project was put on the side for
a long time and they were change of
heads at Paramount
and thank God Scott Rudin had a deal at
the studio many years later and had the
smarts enough to because he knows
theater is a big theater producer to say
I want to take a stab at developing this
with August Wilson and so they worked
together and got a screenplay out of it
and then that kind of went to sleep for
a while and it's kind of had abs and
flows along the way for since the 80s
and fortunately Denzel Washington came
into it and that changed everything for
everybody so to start to talk about the
production of the film a little bit it
feels very authentic to say the least
and I think one of the reasons that is
is because of the of the costumes Sharon
can you talk a little bit about where
you started from - to start your design
work were they original original designs
or did you start by researching the
period or the place I started with the
play and the period you know I I love
the play so I wanted to you know honor
it but I knew we were doing a film which
is you know or work it's more three
dimensional around the street it's a
real location and it becomes
a little more real so we did a lot of
research and there was a amazing books
out of the period of time so I put
together that and Ahmet set the play and
came up with ideas for the clothes were
there a lot of things a big changes that
you needed to make from the costumes
that were in the play to to the film I
would say they were important changes so
a play is so intimate where in film is
so it's so close to you and it was we
were actually in a real location and not
on a stage so I I wanted it always to
feel you would know these people if you
saw them on the street
mm-hm so I had to make that transition
so when you were starting to put
together the scenes were there any rules
in terms of adherence to the the pace of
the play or to you know anything going
in there were rules that I didn't know
about there were good rules
Denzel that everybody when they were in
Pittsburgh were so busy I didn't tell I
mean I this happens to be on almost
every film now we're gonna talk you know
we'll talk every week we talked twice
it's over you know where I get a call at
5:00 in the morning or something like
that but they were so tired so no there
were no rules I mean I knew that I
should adhere to the words because I
learned very quickly that the words were
gonna drive the film the words were the
word the music so but no no I mean it's
it's the same as every film as Denzel
says it's not rocket science but it's
it's as we talked about the editing room
so many times it's let's get the rhythm
right and try to be it in the right
place at the right time but I'll say and
Hughes and I have worked together on a
number of films and Denzel and Hughes
and I did the Great Debaters together
you have to have a skilled sensitive
editor that understands the little tiny
things and the bigger things and he has
a really
really delicate touch otherwise Denzel
and I wouldn't have worked with him
again and and he I mean even his
assemblage when we first saw it it was
pretty great yeah very great so he his
choices that he made I mean that's
that's a very skilled editor you know in
it and it feels seamless hopefully when
you watched it but that that's hard to
do well into the the rhythm of the
language I mean is there a or was there
a substantial difference between
establishing that rhythm on stage versus
I mean it seems like on stage you have
the audience's reactions that you have
to adjust to their gasps their laughs or
whatever and but when you're making a
film you can really dictate and set that
rhythm yourself deliberately we actually
had to do that with the play because I'm
famous so you are yeah so in the plate
Troy Troy Bono and I we come out when we
worsen we come right out talking mm-hmm
we play starts we come walking out well
the first night the audience missed the
first two minutes of the play because
they were screaming and carrying on and
so we had to do this whole remember that
I had to do a fake interest come in act
like I'm doing something put something
down I'd walk all the way through the
house I come all the way to back I'm
like how you do it this yeah I come back
see her so you had to create this whole
stage you know and now I see it with
with you know and I didn't realize that
they do that sometimes on Broadway State
you see oh they give the the name brand
person entrance because you're trying to
get two orders to settle down before yet
this when this was a play got a lot of
responses not a lot of response I I'm
I'm being kind and so we would have to
stop a lot you know um if anything the
film you can get more into the rhythm
more than anything
I remember August because when I did
seven guitar as I did it for a year
mm-hmm we
in different cities before it came to
New York so August would be in
rehearsals all the time and he would get
in this seat get down cross his arms and
his head would go down and I would go oh
my god
August Wilson is falling asleep during
rehearsal
somebody wake him up it's just so
unprofessional and then you'd go and one
of the things that people don't know
about August you never miss a word you
don't you don't drop an end and if or
whatever
it totally screws up the rhythm and
whatever word you come up with is not
gonna be better than the word he has on
the page so you'd be getting in turkette
and then his head would be down like
that then you would miss a word and he
pop up grab his script and go look and
then look at you then look at the script
and stop rehearsal missed an end you
missed in if it messes up the rhythm you
got to go back and do it so he was not
asleep he was listening and but it
speaks to the poetry and the artistry of
the language and and listen as an actor
you've got to say it in a way that
seamless so sometimes people just think
you know it's one of my favorite lines
that choice says it's like so I know
when you talk about Bonnie why don't you
have a job you talk keep talking about
Bonnie got a job why do what that mean
to me Bonnie working I don't care if she
working go [ __ ] for $10 if she
working we're talking about Bonnie
working why ain't you working yeah and
that's music that's the music of yeah
and he wrote what that means to me not
what does that mean to me what that mean
to me what that mean to me Bonnie
working that's doesn't say you know she
doesn't say you know what um from right
now this this child's got a mother she
doesn't say but you know what I'm gone
oh you out right whatever he says you
are womanless man that has power that
has weight and that speaks to the
artistry once again of August Wilson
that's why
up there with the greats well I mean but
viola Rose does so many I guess the word
is contradictory things right her
character I mean she stands up for
herself when Troy pushes her too far but
then on the other hand she stays with
him so I mean how do you how do you
reconcile those aspects of the character
I mean no I reconcile it because that's
what it means to be human if you have
lived any more than five minutes you
know that we are walking contradictions
constantly we are an amalgamation of
saying one thing and meaning another
living one life and we listen my mentor
for 2016 is I'm doing the best I can I
think that's a lot of ours yeah and I
think that once again that's the
artistry of creating human beings is
creating those contradictions and
whenever you're trying to create someone
who makes sense with everything that
they do then what you're doing is you're
cowering to the needs of an audience to
keep them in a seat and to make it easy
for them I always say even with my TV
show this is what I say I say listen you
have to come into my world there'll be
Thursday night at 10 o'clock I'm not
coming into your world because if I'm
coming into your world then you're not
I'm not shifting and changing anything
as an artist that your job is an
audiences to come locked and loaded
it's like Arthur Miller said you know
what I don't write about the finest
people who've ever lived but a terrible
thing has happened to them so their
stories deserve to be told that's the
basis for drama and that was well we
know that this is only one of ten plays
that August Wilson wrote in his
Pittsburgh cycle as it's called and I
think on behalf of everyone you this is
so fantastic one down nine to go for all
of you oh no pressure right please join
me in thanking all of our panelists the
filmmakers of fencing
thank you